[Applaudissements]
je ne savais pas que tu jouais pas là il
faut bien qu'un arbitre pas besoin
d'armes
c'est pas une tenue à jouer au sein
d'une cage et c6 cité mariale anthony
lake a vu la mentalité française médical
gens avec des têtes au sens que je pense
c'est vrai alors on vient vers toi remet
record fait la classe non
ok alors les parisiens pourtant la
meilleure note bertrand 2 3 soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors là c'est la première fois que la
sape a commencé à tourner l'émission
avait 100 ça va tourner comment ça
paraît qu'on le fasse
joe dante l'émission le fait vous allez
bientôt direct sur d8
c'est la première fois je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'on va faire un cache-cache
geo non je vais sortir je vais sortir je
vais compter jusqu'à 20
vous allez tous vous cacher sur le
plateau le premier jeu côté le säntis le
premier que je trouve sur l'oeuf ou d'or
à temps j'avais compté là bas c'est
parti bonne avec moi merci
[Applaudissements]
redécouvrez la musique mettez pas en
marche
[Musique]
j'aime bagages s'est trouvée j'en ai
trouvé il fallait trouver il faut que
c'est trop tôt avec moi c'est quoi venez
me monte monte monte monte monte on doit
regarder mais regardez la dernière j'en
ai trouvé deux j'en ai trouvé de jean
michel mr trouvé c'est bon tu te faisais
grosjean michel mr trouver attention
attention les gars on doit rendre
l'antenne ya les inconnus après mais bon
la cas du tout ma carrière avec derrick
également il est illégal alors si vous
conseille minogue et je cherche gad
elmaleh gad elmaleh gad elmaleh qu'un
nom alors déjà là
connaître chaque roue et s'est trouvée
vers 6-7 attendait alors ensuite qu'est
ce qui nous manque si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes en plein
cache-cache l égard des nations
[Applaudissements]
voilà
et les rues ivan kevala demande que
malade il est au canada
on n'a perdu qu'à madame s'il est
tellement dans le jeu qui ne veut pas
revenir
il a pris ce cache cache très à coeur
car adams va durer un an
c'est surya kabyle combat qui parvient
sombre il a juste le redémarrage tu
démarres quand la le tournage les
[Applaudissements]
non parce qu'ils demandent quand tu
démarres le tournoi on va la faire ses
missions jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient pas il
est en cavale a mis lyon qui avait mis à
l'eau la trouver
[Applaudissements]